arnaud danjean j'ai 48 ans je suis
originaire de saône et loire un
territoire du sud de la bourgogne rural
et agricole où je vis toujours avec ma
famille je suis élue au parlement
européen depuis 2009 dans la région du
grand est j'ai été réélu en 2014 et je
m'occupe particulièrement au parlement
européen des problématiques de sécurité
et de défense
ce choix a été dicté par ma carrière
professionnelle antérieure qui m'avaient
amené à exercer des fonctions au sein du
ministère de la défense en france et au
ministère des affaires étrangères j'ai
donc particulièrement à coeur de
concilier un idéal européen qui
m'apparaît naturel face aux défis que
nous devons relever à l'échelle mondiale
aujourd'hui et le patriotisme qui a
animé tous mes engagements
professionnels et politiques depuis mes
études je pense que nous pouvons et que
nous devons concilier cette exigence
d'un projet européen qui protège nos
concitoyens qui permet de faire face aux
grands défis du 21e siècle mais qui
permet aussi de respecter la diversité
et l'identité de nos nations qui
constitue une richesse des civilisations
extra ordinaire c'est le sens de mon
engagement politique depuis toujours je
me suis engagé en 1991 au sein du rpr et
depuis cette date
j'ai toujours eu à coeur de défendre une
fibre gaulliste populaire patriotes et
européennes
je pense que c'est ce que nous allons
faire pendant cette campagne